you can see I've done a numerical long
division and then a polynomial 1 because
um this is something most of us we
didn't do it very often but it's not
that hard to get back in your head and
polynomials even though like these
questions were completely different
right whoa although this garbage in here
you're really going to do much the same
process so if you can see the pan here
you can move forward and do it here
in fact that's kind of one of the things
I love about maths that you know what
maths does the power of s is it strips
away how something looks on the outside
and it gets at the core of what the
problem really is and often you'll see
like all these commonalities between
different problems mathematically good
morning that you wouldn't see otherwise
so let's take these other ones you've
given me go write 5,000 where you divide
by 7 so I begin one and be dealing by
doing about long division sign I put
mine doesn't remember what they're
called the number then we're dividing by
it's cold it's the divisor divides up
right what we're dividing is called that
morning is called a dividend
okay and the answer that we're going to
get up here will be the quotient okay
now if it divides exactly neatly then
you'll get a little of the question okay
but good morning we also will get a
remainder right and and in this case we
look so let's keep this a good go seven
what do I do with this thing first so
where does it go he goes into five but
of course I can't fit it in there so
then we appeal to the next I'm up 50
how many sevens do I fit in there seven
because they aren't the biggest multiple
you can fit is 49 okay it's not like it
was seven what I do that a lot
multiply out the front which gives me 49
I subtract and then I get a one which
seven again can't go into so then I
bring down that zero now what do I do
how many go in which is on one okay so
now I multiply out the front I do
another subtraction which gives me three
okay and then I've always say at the end
now what I'll do with the three it's
going to fit yeah so I bring this zero
down here 30 and there are humming
sevens again hold on full okay I bring
that one more time 7 times 4 is 28 and
my subtraction leaves me with 2 and
there are no more numbers there no more
zeros to bring down a little bit more
any a little bit so that too is what's
left that's the remainder okay
now even though I didn't ask you to do
it I just want you to point out what we
can conclude from this like a concluding
statement I can say that 5,000 is equal
to this is the other dividend it's equal
to the divisor times the question
seven times seven hundred and fourteen
plus our remainder
yeah plus plus two okay now one of the
things which I didn't point out last
time you can do it in this is this is
actually a transformation I talked about
this to some of the authors this is a
transformation to turn division into a
mix numeral right so for example have a
look at this line key if I divide
everything by seven every single time
there I would get 5,000 divided by seven
seven times seven hundred fourteen
divided by seven and 2/7 it's an
equation so I've done the same thing to
the left on the right
everything's sweet okay but you can see
I can simplify this right good morning
5,000 divided by seven what kind of
fraction is that it has a name starts
with an i it's improper because my
numerator is too big
good morning so I can convert it into a
week zero using this just by taking the
division line and dividing everything
through the 17th will clearly cancel so
I have 740 and then we have a whole
number and a proper fraction we just
kind of stick them together and we call
that good morning we call that a mixed
evil
okay so this is I mean I know our
calculators can do this but this is how
it works and in fact this will become
useful to us when we think about this
guy okay so anyhow big ste rule that's
all fine let's move let's transition
back into polynomials and what we've
just done what our brain is gone through
in order to do this will help us as we
do this later okay so I'm going to draw
my division side nice long thinking
because my polynomial is quite large 2 X
cubed minus x squared plus 5x take away
3 ok I'm dividing by this so remembering
that in polynomials the one important
thing that's a complete shift and isn't
in parallel yeah is that the thing that
really matters the terms that really
matters a matter are the X's right the
X's are what I'm interested in so the
first thing I'd ask is how many X's fit
into 2x cubed and here's just to expand
I'm just dividing that's all I'm doing
right it's a 2x squared and just like I
did before I'm going to multiply back
down okay
so let's go through this place in person
multiply gives me 2x cubed plus 4x
squared ok with that
2 times 2x win yep now my subtraction
right be careful cuz you've got a
negative up the top there minus x
squared minus 4x squared minus 5 right
minus 5 x squared and then I'm going to
bring down this plus 5x along for the
ride okay how many times does X go into
this guy
it goes in minus 5 x times minus 5
inside and now I multiply back around
the front so let's see minus 5x squared
that times that minus 10x do you see
that
okay now watch out I'm subtracting you
all the way down okay but there's a
negative that I'm subtracting so I've
got a double negative
yeah right so when I subtract I get
careful careful
five take away negative 10 so that the
cancellation is in the middle right so
it actually becomes 5 plus 10 so that
way 15 is that okay I'll bring down that
minus 3 for the right and here's my last
time on the AUSA's how many times is X
fit into 15 X just 15 that's good
good I'll multiply one last time 15 X
plus B and now we'll do my final
subtraction minus 3 takeaway 30 minus 3
takeaway 30 minus 3 so this my remainder
now I want to point out something a
little bit unusual every time you do a
numerical long division okay your
remainder will always be positive every
single time okay you'll have her made of
2 or remainder 3 or maybe 4 you can't
get a remained a bigger than 7 by the
way or begin with 6 in fact why not why
can't you get a remainder bigger than 6
good I'm dividing by 7 so for instance
if I if I went through this calculation
and somehow I got out the end oh I've
got remainder 7 um that means I could
have fit another 70 I shouldn't have a
remainder 7 right but when polynomials
things are a little bit different okay
um you will frequently get Omega that's
negative and the reason why is because
this number can be negative but you know
what we're really interested in is the
exes right the exes are the important
part okay and we can content ourselves
that this is true by again writing this
statement in let's let's conclude by
doing that so again let me just lay me
this right we've got the the dividend
yeah that's the first thing I have is
the divisor times the quotient
plus the remainder that's how I form
this statement okay we jump by the way
in case you how to do this it's a total
for instance really this is alphabetical
if you can't remember which ones which
so dividend divisor portion remainder
that's how it goes in order okay so
let's write this out the dividend is
this big one can I started with two X
cubed minus x squared plus 5x take away
three is my dividend is equal to the
divisor X plus two times the quotient 2x
squared minus 5x plus 15 plus the
remainder but my reign is negative so
that means it's minus 33 now last time
we went through this process we actually
took this guy and we expanded it and we
found after every to simplify it out
even with weird numbers in there like
495 I think was the number we ended up
with it all comes out in the wash
provided we've done it correctly okay
alright now that was revision this
lesson we're gonna do two things number
one and we're gonna look at some of the
problems that you can the introductory
promise the basic ones you can start to
approach with this skill and then
secondly you notice this is taking some
time right this is a lengthy process I
mean the name it's called long division
for goodness sake right it's a long
process I'm going to show you a much
quicker way to go through the same thing
and get the same results but it's far
more efficient